your intuition that
a strong AGI versus weak AGI type
systems
could be fundamentally different
can you unpack that intuition a little
bit Yeah I think there's multiple
thresholds
an example is the point at which
a system has sufficient intelligence and
situational awareness and understanding
of human psychology that it would have
the capability to desire to do so to
fake being aligned like it knows what
responses demons are looking for and can
compute the responses looking humans are
looking for and give those responses
without it necessarily being the case
that it is sincere about that you know
the it's a very understandable way for
an intelligent being to act humans do it
all the time imagine if your plan for
um
you know achieving a good government is
you're going to ask anyone who requests
to be dictator of the country
um
if they're a good person
and if they say no you don't let them be
dictator
now the reason this doesn't work is that
people can be smart enough to realize
that the answer you're looking for is
yes I'm a good person and say that even
if they're not really good people
so
the work of alignment might be
qualitatively different
above that throat threshold of
intelligence or beneath it it doesn't it
doesn't have to be like a very sharp
threshold but you know like
there's the there's the point where
you're like Building A system that is
not in some sense know you're out there
and it's not in some sense smart enough
to fake anything
and there's a point where the system is
definitely that smart and there are
weird in-between cases like
jpt4 which
you know like we have no insight into
what's going on in there and so we don't
know to what extent there's like a thing
that in some sense has learned what
responses the reinforcement learning by
human feedback is trying to entrain and
is like calculating how to give that
versus like
aspects of it that naturally talk that
way have been reinforced I I wonder if
there could be measures of how
manipulative a thing is so I think of uh
Prince mishkin character from uh The
Idiot by
uh Dostoevsky is this kind of a
perfectly purely naive character
I wonder if there's a spectrum between
zero manipulation
transparent naive almost to the point of
naiveness to
sort of deeply Psychopathic
manipulative and I wonder if it's
possible too I would avoid the term
Psychopathic like humans can be
Psychopaths and AI that was never you
know like never had that stuff in the
first place it's not like a defective
human it's its own thing but leaving
that aside well as a small aside I
wonder if what part of psychology which
has its flaws as a discipline already
could be mapped or expanded to include
AI systems that sounds like a dreadful
mistake just like start over with AI
systems if they're imitating humans who
have known psychiatric disorders then
sure you may be able to predict
it like if you then sure like if you ask
it to behave in a psychotic fashion and
it obligingly does so then you may be
able to predict its responses by using
the theory of psychosis but if you're
just yeah like no like start over with
yeah don't drag the psychology I I just
disagree with that I mean it's a it's a
beautiful idea to start over but I don't
I think fundamentally the system is
trained on human data on language from
the internet and it's currently aligned
with uh rlhf uh reinforcement learning
with human feedback
so humans are constantly in the loop of
the training procedure so it feels like
in some fundamental way
it is training what it means to to think
and speak like a human so that I mean
there must be aspects of psychology that
are they're mappable just like you said
with Consciousness it's part of the text
so I I mean there's the question of to
what extent it is thereby being made
more human-like versus to what extent an
alien actress is learning to play human
characters
I thought that's what I'm constantly
trying to do when I interact with other
humans is trying to fit in trying to
play the a a robot trying to play human
characters
so I don't know how much of human
interaction is trying to play a
character versus being Who You Are
I don't I don't really know what it
means to be a social human I do think
that the that
those people who go through their whole
lives wearing masks and never take it
off because they don't know the internal
mental motion for taking it off
or think that the mask that they wear
just is themselves
I think those people are closer to the
masks that they wear than an alien from
another planet would
like learning how to predict the next
word that every kind of human on the
internet says
mask is an interesting word
but if you're always wearing a mask
in public and in private aren't you the
mask
like I mean I I think that you are more
than the mask I think the mask is a
slice through you it may even be the
slice that's in charge of you yeah but
if your self-image is of somebody who
never
gets angry or something
and yet your voice starts to tremble
under certain circumstances there's a
thing that's inside you that the mask
says isn't there
and that like even the mask you wear
internally is like telling inside your
own stream of Consciousness is not there
and yet it is there it's a perturbation
on this little on this slice through you
how beautifully did you put it it's a
slice through you it may even be a slice
that controls you
I'm gonna think about that for a while
I mean I personally uh I try to be
really good to other human beings I try
to put love out there I try to be the
exact same person in public exam and
private
but it's a set of principles I operate
under I'm I have a temper I have an ego
I have flaws
how much of it
how much have I how much of the
subconscious
am I aware how much am I existing in
this slice and how much of that is who I
am
um in in this context of AI
the thing I present to the world and to
myself in the private of my own mind
when I look in the mirror how much is
that who I am similar with AI the thing
it presents in conversation how much is
that who it is
because to me if it sounds human and it
always sounds human
it awfully starts to become something
like human
no unless there's an alien actress who
is learning how to sound human
okay he's getting good at it boy to you
that's a fundamental difference that's a
that's a really deeply important
difference if it looks the same if it
quacks like a duck
if it does all duck-like things but it's
an alien actress underneath that's
fundamentally different
if in fact there's a whole bunch of
thought going on in there which is very
unlike human thought and is directed
around like okay what would a human do
over here
and
well first of all I think it matters
because there are there's you know like
insides are real and do not match
outsides like the inside of like the a
brick is not like a hollow shell
containing only a surface there's an
inside of the brick if you like put it
into an x-ray machine you can see the
inside of the brick
um
and
you know you know just because we cannot
understand what's going on inside GPT
does not mean that that it is not there
a blank map does not correspond to a
blank territory
I think it is like
predictable with near certainty that if
we knew what was going on inside GPT or
let's say gpt3 or even like gpt2 to take
one of the systems that like has
actually been open sourced by this point
if I recall correctly
um
like if we knew it was actually going on
there there is no doubt in my mind that
there are some things it's doing that
are not exactly what a human does if you
train a thing that is not architected
like a human to predict the next output
that anybody on the internet would make
this does not get you this agglomeration
of all the people on the internet that
that like rotates the person you're
looking for into place and then
simulates that per and then like
simulates the internal processes of that
person one to one it like it is to some
degree an alien actress it cannot
possibly just be like a bunch of
different people in there exactly like
the people but how much of it is like
learn how much of it is by gradient
descent
getting optimized to perform similar
thoughts as humans think in order to
predict human outputs versus being
optimized to carefully consider how to
play a role how to like how humans work
predict the the actress the predictor
that in a different way than humans do
well you know that's the kind of
question that with like 30 years of work
by half the planet's physicists we can
maybe start to answer you think so I
think that's that difficult so to get to
I think you just gave it as an example
that a strong AGI could be fundamentally
different from a weak AGI because there
not could be an alien actress in there
that's manipulating well there's a
difference so I think like even gp22
probably has like a like very stupid
fragments of alien actress in it there's
there's a difference between like the
notion that the actress is somehow
manipulative like for example dbt3 I'm
guessing
to whatever extent there's an alien
actress in there versus like something
that that mistakenly believes it's a
human as it were well not well you know
maybe not even being a person
um
so like the question of like
like prediction via alien actress
cogitating versus prediction via being
isomorphic to the thing predicted is a
spectrum
and
even into what and to whatever extent
this is an alien actress I'm not sure
that there's like a whole person alien
actress with like different goals
from predicting the next step being
manipulative or anything like that but
that might be gpt5 or GPT 6 even but
that's the strong AGI you're concerned
about as an example you're providing why
we can't do research on AI alignment
effectively on gpt4 that would apply to
gpt6 it's it's one of a bunch of things
that change at different points
I'm trying to get out ahead of the curve
here but you know if you imagine what
the textbook from the future would say
if we'd actually been able to study this
for 50 years without killing ourselves
and without transcending and you like
just imagine like a wormhole opens and a
textbook from that impossible World
falls out yes the textbook is not going
to say there is a single sharp threshold
where everything changes it's going to
be like of course we know that like best
practices for aligning these systems
must like take into account the
following like seven major thresholds of
importance which are passed at the
following suffer in different points
yeah is what the textbook is going to
say
I asked this question of Sam Allman
which if gbt is the thing that unlocks
AGI which version of GPT will be in the
textbooks as the fundamental leap and he
said a similar thing that it just seems
to be a very linear thing I don't think
anyone it we won't know for a long time
what was the big leap the textbook isn't
going to think it isn't going to talk
about big leaps because big leaps are
the way you think when you have like a
very simple model of a very simple
scientific model of what's going on
where it's just like all this stuff is
there or all the stuff is not there
or like there's a single quantity and
it's like increasing linearly it's like
the textbook would say like well and
then gpt3 had like capability w x y and
and gpt4 had like capability Z1 Z2 and
Z3
like not in terms of what it can
externally do but in terms of like
internal Machinery that started to be
present
it's just because we have no idea of
what the internal Machinery is that we
are not already seeing like chunks of
Machinery appearing piece by piece as
they no doubt have been we just don't
know what they are
but don't you think there could be
whether you put in the category of
Einstein
with Theory relativity so very concrete
models of reality they're considered to
be giant leaps in our understanding or
or someone like Sigmund Freud or more
kind of mushy
theories of the human mind don't you
think we'll have big potentially big
leaps and understanding of that kind in
Into the Depths of these systems
sure but like humans having great leaps
in their map their understanding of the
system is a very different concept from
the system itself acquiring new chunks
of machinery
so the rate at which it acquires that
Machinery might
accelerate faster than our understanding
oh it's been like vastly exceeding the
yeah the right to which it's getting
capabilities is vastly overracing our
ability to understand what's going on in
there